One last thing I'd like to talk about is the fact that
the Datastore is sharded in some way
and replicated.
Google doesn't really share details
of how this is implemented
at a very low level,
but a lot of the constraints that we'll be dealing with
imply that the database is both sharded and replicated.
So there are some really nice properties here.
One is that you are not going to have to think about scaling--
too much.
Your queries will generally be quick
because they have to be simple.
And we might have to think about consistency,
which is why I talked a little bit about
replication lag so much before in an Intro Class.
Because things are sharded and sometimes
your data changes and updates
take time to propagate through the system,
we're going to actually have to acknowledge the fact that
we're in a big database system
and things may not always be consistent in all cases.
It's easy to work around these cases, but
it is something you have to do consciously.
Let's do a quick quiz.
Do you understand everything there is to know
about the App Engine Datastore?